mais battu les meilleurs c'est
l'apothéose et après le match les
joueurs avaient un t-shirt avec marc et
c'est drôle ça tu sais ce qu'on dit dans
ton dos on t'aime aldo c'est génial et
vous étiez tellement touchée que
d'habitude vous allez vous cacher dans
les jardins de bercy toujours et là vous
êtes venu sur le podium c'est le moment
que jamais vous tapez votre code 4 ce
jour le nom de l'ue raison je pense
qu'on est alors l'entraîneur suédois
johnson vous inviter dans sa maison à
marbella ouais j'y allais ne sais pas et
les grossesses ça c'est pas sur wii vous
qu aimer les femmes mais jamais relatant
même invité avec ma compagne lala cas et
que j'aurai la glace est pas tout à fait
pareil ouais
bien alors vous finissez comme comme
jacquet a un petit peu non oui il ya une
petite différence avant c'est que moi
j'avais annoncé avant que j'allais
m'arrêter ouais c'est vrai lui la noce
et sur le péroné lisez
moi j'avais décidé depuis quelques temps
qu'il était temps de fou de passer à
autre chose et c'était donc qu'en fait
mon baroud d'honneur comme un gardien
occasion de m'illustrer vous partez vous
dit j'ai tout donné ronde aujourd'hui je
suis au bout du rouleau un peu comme
un peu comme bruno solo et à vous
arrêter chacun sur une victoire même
quand
il a commencé en 85 lui ça fait 1 ça
fait 15 ans alors quand chirac il j'ose
pas son entrée dans les vestiaires pour
vous saluer ça fait quoi ça
écoutez moi je suis quelqu'un qui garde
toujours beaucoup de réserve antoine y
est c'est vrai que c'est assez
symbolique parce qu'ils descendent pas
n'importe quand n'importe où ils
descendent que quand on a gagné ces
trois grands ballons n'ont pas gagné il
cède pas à gagner ils viennent pas
villemomble est clair c'est une
reconnaissance il y en avait une
occasion l'a pas ratée est en mouvement
nous vous il va falloir que j'apprenne à
aimer d'autres gens que les handballeurs
oui non pas que j'ai toujours beaucoup
aimé les emballeurs mais ils
monopolisaient un petit peu mon
attention et donc d'un petit peu mon
affection c'est vrai maintenant il va
falloir passer à autre chose que vous
êtes grand père ne se passe bien très
faut s'occuper du petit écoutez on va
voir ce que ça donne tout au long de ma
vie j'ai pas être des capable de
m'occuper des gens que j'aime et qui
m'aiment et désormais j'aurais pu les
excuses du boulot voila voila j'ai
encore quelques jours un si vous voulez
m'a donné quelques jours et après
mais ça vous embête quand même ça
d'arrêter parce que vous serez la télé
c'est sympa les médias vous dites on dit
toujours que la pression médiatique et
pénible mais c'est une sacrée façon
d'exister sur aix d'efforts
surtout ça m'interpelle quoi est ce que
on est capable de vivre après ça quoi
c'est la question ouais alors ben on va
quand même oui j'espère ouais ouais non
mais je mettrais dans le public moi ça
me suffit de parler alors que votre
équipe vous n'êtes ni papa ni père
fouettard voulez gérer comment les mecs
pour les faire gagner il ya eu plusieurs
ou laïcité un petit peu tous les
sobriquets dont j'étais beaucoup plus
directif avec ses fameux barjots qui les
nie complètement donc il fallait à
certains moments entre qui avait une
autorité avec l'équipe là qui est
échappé du monde c'était beaucoup plus
en pointillés beaucoup plus soft bon
c'est vrai que le soft à sydney ça a été
une catastrophe
par contre ici ça a bien marché comme
quoi signe de passage obligé il faut des
fois
exactement où vous partez mais tout le
monde sera là non je sais pas moi je
suis pas un grand spécialiste du
handball mais ont-ils casa richardson
martini s'en vont bon inutile c'est sur
les autres on va essayer un petit peu de
fr revenir sur leur décision parce
qu'ils sont quand même encore
indispensable parce que vous ai dit en
parlant de richardson c'est lui qui a
permis de gravir les échelons définitif
oui c'est un mec exceptionnel
exceptionnel
oui
gilles à emballer des gonzesses daniel
nature tout en vous avez 57 ans est né à
marseille par encore ce magasin
d'articles de sport fils de bourgeois
marseillais échauffement politique en
revanche vous n'êtes pas suivi la ligne
familiale ah oui vous étiez plutôt
gauchiste mais pas tout de suite car je
suis prêt tout de suite les communistes
à l'italienne cool voilà à l'époque où
c'était une grande allégorie populaires
ont rêvé d'être 30% bon tu t'es la
limite 30% mais oui c'était un rêve est
maintenant en maintenant je reste je
reste je suis manichéen moment de voter
ça c'est clair je préfère être du côté
de ceux qui souffrent sommes allés un
peu un cliché mais pas du tout militant
j'ai voté à gauche je vote à gauche
avait tourné le dos à une vie assez
ranger au départ vous auriez pu
reprendre le magasin d'articles de sport
en
gt2
maintenant c'est toujours pareil
cantonné n'a pas pas de commerce n'est
ce pas
cartonné fils de commerçants ou alors ça
devient quasiment une vocation vous
naissez là dedans ou alors vous n'avez
de cesse que de vous en démarquer moi je
me suis pas vraiment démarqué parce que
j'ai toujours un petit peu aidé à la
boutique mes parents étaient quand même
très heureux que j'embrasse une
profession plus plus cool quoi parce que
c'est vrai qu'à sénia c'est quand même
plus cool que commerçant oui c'est ça
sert vous êtes venus vous êtes devenu
prof de gym un classement en fait vos
premiers souvenirs de sport c'est à
marseille c'est sûr là sur la place la
mort de marcel cerdan
était pétri d du jeune âge baigné dans
ce milieu a indiscutablement vous ai
fait du hand parce que c'était au pied
de la maison et le
maire avait la trouille pourtant
j'ai pas le souvenir qu'à l'époque
marseille était une ville qui avait une
mauvaise réputation mais elles voyaient
pas d'un bon oeil que son gamin qui de
11 ou 12 ans il traverse la ville
le hand c'est là en bas de la maison il
y avait peut-être aussi le problème des
devoirs il fallait revenir sa vie de
voir céline notamment de la vie lui
reviendra jamais cru en l'été c'est
quand même le volet balou ball volley
ball volley ball sur la plage était fait
non mais c'est bien ou pas
agitez côté oui je me suis mis très tard
comme tous ceux qui démarrent très tard
dans quelque chose après une espèce de
bouillie me enfin une boulimie
n'exagérons rien quoi famille donc je
lui en
iroko site fellini
avait failli être médecin finalement
suite été ma vocation mais j'étais trop
fait les entiers d'etelan mais voilà
quand la voiture de sport les les
françaises oui vous été trois fois
champion de france avec le smuc on
disait à l'époque
forgé une réputation un peu quand même
deux on peut le dire sans vous vexer un
peu de petits branleurs non non non mais
c'est plus que de réputation était
dilettante aux manières en l'heure c'est
un peu péjoratif
tv d'état j'aimais bien me faire les
choses sans trop d'effort quoi
leur prof de gym effectivement puis un
jour il dit mon prof de gym on essaie de
faire du bien aux gens de mettre dans sa
peau ça vous fait pas marrer vous dites
je m'occupais de sport de plus haut
niveau depuis janvier c'est quand même
aussi chiant le truc vraiment important
c'est de faire gagner des gens ouais
enfin c'est à dire que des mecs qui
tourne autour d'un ballon toute la
journée sans envie de gagner ça vous
semble pas non plus un but dans la vie
quoi je suis pas sûr que ça a été aussi
déterminé que sa main qui a une
succession d'événements dans ma vie qui
ont fait que je suis arrivé très vite
dans la recherche de la performance et
si ça a été mon truc courage monsieur
romain épanouie après l'équipe de france
en 85 10 ans après c'est ridge à vic
champion du monde justement après lui la
plante est sydney un peu moins bien
signer c'est épouvantable pour vous
puisque vous perdez votre père au moment
au moment des jeux olympiques donc ça a
été quand vous avez jamais rien déléguer
à personne évidemment personne ne vous a
aidé c'est le problème des gens qui
développent pas de stars mais ça c'est
la section là vous auriez bien aimé ce
jour là qui est quelqu'un qui vous dise
daniel ton fait pas va pleurer dans la
chambre je contacte de l'équipe
voilà alors 6e place à sydney là vous
dites je suis mort vous dites toujours
je suis mort d'ailleurs pas ce que vous
dites je ne suis pas sûr vivants je suis
en revenant donc c'est vrai que là
vraiment vous êtes mes origines j'ai
vraiment eu l'impression
professionnellement la de
non pas d'avoir fait la compétition de
trop mais d'avoir fait la compétition
fatale vrai mais c'est vrai que vous
avez vues dans l'oeil d'un joueur là il
faut que tu t'arrêtes ouais ben ou deux
essais mais c'est vrai que c'est savait
il faut toujours se donner des repères
dans la vie tant que faire se peut et
moi j'avais décidé que ça allait pas
être
responsable de la fédération ça n'allait
pas être mon environnement affectif ça
n'allait pas être une forte réflexion
sur moi-même qui allez me dire il faut
car être j'allais piqué cette
information dans les yeux parce que je
crois beaucoup moins on regarde c'est à
dire quand j'entraîne les gens cachent
par l'audience je le regarde dans les
yeux et j'essaie de prendre des
informations il savait était ça toujours
été mon idée que c'est de là qu'elle est
venir le moment de dire basta
perez était clair est-ce que vous êtes
heureux là parce que c'est pas une
grande capacité au bonheur vous dit vous
êtes athée d'abord on croyait pas en
dieu 8 le paradis sur terre je vais
parfois fréquenté mais je ne rêve pas
d'un paradis dans l'au delà donc déjà
pour vous le paradis des sur terre il
est par ailleurs sur terre et vous dites
aussi le bonheur ne m'appartient pas je
ne les ressentent si qu'à de très rares
occasions il c'est vrai que j'ai
longtemps travaillé en me disant que
pour être au service des autres il
fallait se mettre un petit peu entre
parenthèses je ne suis pas mal revenu là
dessus ces derniers temps parce que le
temps presse aussi et c'est vrai que
j'ai bien profité ces derniers tard à la
fois tirer des résultats sportifs et
aussi de joie personnelle je passe
légitime donc vous êtes rattraper j'ai
essayé